noch ist etwas Zeit die Reihen haben
sich zwar schon gefüllt wie ich sehe ist
der Kanzler auch schon da auch
Außenministerin baerbock aber bevor es
losgeht würde ich gerne noch meine
Kollegin Ines Trams aus unserem
Hauptstadtstudio begrüßen die vor Ort im
Bundestag ist Ines was ist denn heute
von dieser Debatte zu erwarten nach dem
Machtwort des Kanzlers
na ich denke es werden die
unterschiedlichen Sichtweisen zu genau
diesem Machtspruch des Kanzlers von
Montag aufeinanderprallen er selber Olaf
Scholz denke ich wird ja selbstgewiss
darauf verweisen dass er ja nun
entschieden habe die drei noch
verbleibenden Atommeiler in Deutschland
über diesen Winter hinauslaufen zu
lassen und dass er somit ja die
Energiesicherheit für diesen kommenden
Winter gewährleistet habe auf der
anderen Seite werden wir
unionsfraktionschef Merz hören von der
größten Oppositionspartei und er wird
genau dieses Machtwort auslegen als ein
Zeichen von Ohnmacht des Kanzlers der
eben nicht vermocht hat ohne Machtwort
die beiden Streithähne Habeck und
Lindner auseinander zu bringen ja bis
hierhin erstmal herzlichen dank ihnen
wir haben gesehen Friedrich Merz ist
auch inzwischen da hatte einen kurzen
Austausch mit Olaf Scholz und wir
schalten jetzt rüber ins Parlament zu
Bundestagspräsidentin Bärbel Bass
vor Eintritt in die Tagesordnung
gratuliere ich
nachträglich dem Kollegen Dr Helge braun
zu seinem 50 Geburtstag
[Musik]
alles Gute im Namen des ganzen Hauses
ich komme nun zur Tagesordnung
interfraktionell wurde vereinbart dass
den Tagesordnungspunkt 8 Buchstabe a
abzusetzen und Buchstabe b mit denen
ohne debattenpunkten aufzurufen im
Anschluss an Tagesordnungspunkt 7 sollen
nun Tagesordnungspunkt 14 mit einer
debattenzeit von nunmehr 68 Minuten
beraten werden die weiteren
Tagesordnungspunkte der cdu/csu-fraktion
am heutigen Tag sollen entsprechend
vorrücken wobei der Tagesordnungspunkt
20 nun mit einer geänderten debattenzeit
von 39 Minuten beraten werden soll
der zunächst ohne Aussprache vorgesehene
Zusatzpunkt drei Buchstabe c soll nun im
Anschluss an top 19 mit einer Debatte
von 26 Minuten beraten werden
Tage so lange hier noch über die
Tagesordnung und die
Geschäftsordnungsdebatte debattiert wird
schalten wir noch mal rüber zu Ines
Trams zu meiner Kollegin Ines nach
diesem Machtwort des Kanzlers wie ist
denn da überhaupt eine weitere
Zusammenarbeit innerhalb der Ampel
möglich ist das Klima nicht deutlich
vergiftet dadurch
ich denke schon dass das Klima vergiftet
ist das auch das Misstrauen gewachsen
ist zwischen den drei ampelianern und
man muss sehen dass dieses Machtwort so
denke ich zumindest ja tatsächlich nur
oberflächlich und eben auch nur begrenzt
etwas Ruhe in die Koalition bringen wird
denn das Kanzler Scholz bereits so früh
sich das Machtwort bedienen musste zeigt
ja wie fragil die Ampel aufgestellt ist
so jetzt schalten wir ins Parlament weil
ich höre das jetzt ein ganz besonderer
Gast dort noch begrüßt wird
zu uns gemacht haben
sie waren selbst ein Kind als die
Deutschen
1941 in die Ukraine einfielen und sie
mit ihrer Familie ins Ghetto verfrachtet
wurden seit 30 Jahren engagieren sie
sich für die jüdischen Überlebenden der
Ghettos und Konzentrationslager in der
Ukraine und ganz besonders in ihrer
Heimatstadt
und sie setzen sich mit aller Kraft
dafür ein dass die Opfer des Holocaust
nicht vergessen werden dass ihre
Geschichten weitergetragen werden und
ihrer in Würde gedacht werden ich danke
Ihnen für dieses große und wichtige
Engagement es ist uns eine Ehre Sie
heute hier im Deutschen Bundestag
begrüßen zu dürfen
[Musik]
überlebt ist sondern die Nazis töteten
seinen Bruder und jetzt muss er dauernd
Schutz suchen vor den russischen Raketen
Marie-Luise Beck wir sehen das gerade
die grüne Politikerin hat sich ja immer
sehr für die Ukraine eingesetzt hat
ihnen hierher gebracht das ist Teil der
historischen Verantwortung Deutschlands
etwa anderthalb Millionen Jüdin und
Juden wurden in der Ukraine ermordet
mehr als 2000 Tatorte des Massenmordes
liegen auf dem Gebiet der heutigen
Ukraine jüdische Frauen Männer und
Kinder wurden zusammengetrieben sie
wurden erschossen wie in der Schlucht
vom barbinar oder verbrannt in Odessa
auch hakif mariopol oder luhansk waren
Tatorte des Verbrechens Ort die viele
von uns in Deutschland erst seit einigen
Monaten kennen seit Russlands Überfall
auf die Ukraine der russische Präsident
begründet den völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg
gegen die Ukraine mit der Lüge eine
angeblich notwendigen Entnazifizierung
damit
missbraucht der in perfider Weise die
Geschichte des deutschen
Vernichtungskrieges gegen die
Sowjetunion und des Völkermordes an den
Juden Europas Millionen haben ihre
Heimat verlassen auf der Flucht vor Tod
und Gewalt ungezählte tausende sind
diesem Krieg bereits zum Opfer gefallen
darunter Überlebende des Holocaust wie
Boris romanschenko der das KZ Buchenwald
überlebte und dem dieses Haus im März
gedachte
unter den vielen Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainern die bei uns Zuflucht gefunden
haben sind jüdische Kinder und
pflegebedürftige Holocaust Überlebende
sie können dank der gemeinsamen
Initiative jüdischer Organisationen in
der Ukraine und in Deutschland
evakuiert werden im Namen des ganzen
Hauses danke ich allen die diese
Rettungsaktion durch ihr Engagement
möglich gemacht haben lieber Roman
lieber Roman Schwarzmann wir stehen an
der Seite der Ukrainerin und Ukrainer
unser Ziel ist der Frieden in Freiheit
vielen Dank dass Sie heute bei uns sind
[Applaus]
nun ist es wie immer wir steigen in die
Tagesordnung ein
ich rufe auf den Tagesordnungspunkt 7
die Abgabe einer Regierungserklärung
durch den Bundeskanzler zum Europäischen
Rat am 20 und 21 Oktober
2022 für die Aussprache im Anschluss an
die Regierungserklärung wurde eine Dauer
von 90 Minuten vereinbart
das Wort hat zur Abgabe der
Regierungserklärung der Bundeskanzler
Herr Olaf Scholz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren
der brutale Krieg in der Ukraine Putins
rücksichtsloser Einsatz von Hunger und
Energie als Waffe die enormen
Preissteigerung hier bei uns und
weltweit Deutschland und Europa gehen
durch Bewährungsproben wie wir sie seit
Jahrzehnten nicht erlebt haben
Bewährungsproben die Putin uns mit
seinem imperialistischen Angriffskrieg
aufgezwungen hat
der Krieg setzt menschliche Schwäche
voraus und gegen sie ist der gerichtet
schreibt Carl von klausewitz
Putin handelt danach aber zieht die
Ukraine mit Terror er droht der Welt
unverhohlen und vollkommen
verantwortungslos mit dem Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen er will Angst sehen
Spalten und einschüchtern er spekuliert
auf unsere Schwäche
aber er irrt sich wir sind nicht schwach
unser Land steht zusammen Europa steht
zusammen und zeigt Solidarität
untereinander und mit der Ukraine unsere
weltweiten Allianzen sind stark und
lebendig wie nie putin wird seine
Kriegsziele nicht erreichen
als Putin den Krieg im Februar begann
haben manche gemutmaßt in wenigen Tagen
ist die Ukraine besiegt auch Putin
selbst hat das geglaubt
nun es ist anders gekommen es ist anders
gekommen weil die Ukraine und Ukraine
ihr Land so tapfer verteidigen und der
hohen schmerzhaften
Opfern befreien es ist anders gekommen
aber auch deshalb weil die Partner der
Ukraine darunter auch wir das Land
unterstützt haben politisch finanziell
humanitär und mit Waffen
Artillerie und Luftabwehr ist genau das
was die Ukraine besonders dringend
braucht und genau das liefern wir
moderne Panzerhaubitzen und mehrfach
Raketenwerfer zum Beispiel den
panzerringtausch mit Tschechien der
Slowakei Griechenland und Slowenien hat
manch einer auch in diesem Haus als
rohrkrippierer kritisiert inzwischen ist
klar auf diese Weise bekommt die Ukraine
rund 100 Panzer mit denen ihre Soldaten
sofort umgehen können
als eines der ersten Länder haben wir
der Ukraine Anfang Juni moderne
luftverteidigungssysteme zugesagt ein
erstes davon haben wir letzte Woche an
unsere ukrainischen Freunde übergeben
früher als ursprünglich geplant drei
weitere werden so schnell wie es geht
folgen
wir haben fliegerabwehrraketen geliefert
so wie Gepard Panzer über die es
zunächst auf fies die bringen doch
nichts dafür gebe es nicht mal genügend
Munition heute sehen wir welchen
Unterschied sie ausmachen
wie überlebenswichtig unsere
Unterstützung ist das zeigen die
brutalen russischen Raketen und
Drohnenangriffe auf zivile Ziele die wir
in den vergangenen zwei Wochen erlebt
haben wahllos fallen ihnen Frauen Männer
und Kinder zum Opfer
ja selbst diejenigen die wie Sie sehr
geehrter Schwarzmann den Terror und die
Verfolgung durch die Nationalsozialisten
überlebt haben müssen erneut um ihr
Leben fürchten dass Sie heute hier unser
Gast sind ehrt und sehr
wir lassen auch die jüngsten Eskalation
moskauz nicht unbeantwortet mit einem
weiteren Sanktionspaket haben wir als EU
den Druck auf die russische Regierung
noch einmal erhöht bei diesem Kurs
bleibt es so lange Russland seinen
brutalen Angriffskrieg fortsetzt und
auch im Kreis der G7 Staats- und
Regierungschefs haben wir vergangene
Woche gemeinsam mit Präsident selenski
bekräftigt bewusste Angriffe auf die
Zivilbevölkerung sind Kriegsverbrechen
um es klar zu sagen auch eine solche
Taktik der verbrannten Erde wird
Russland nicht helfen den Krieg zu
gewinnen sie stärkt nur die
Entschlossenheit und den
Durchhaltewillen der Ukraine und ihrer
Partner
am Ende ist Russlands Bomben und Raketen
Terror eine Verzweiflungstat genauso wie
die Mobilisierung russischer Männer für
den Krieg
damit ist der Krieg endgültig im Herzen
der russischen Gesellschaft angekommen
in den Familien und auf der Straße
hunderttausende Russen entziehen sich
der Rekrutierung viele verlassen das
Land all die Lügen und Propaganda das
Gerede von
spezialoperationen und schnellen Siegen
alles nur Fassade wie ein Podium
die Ukraine wird sich erfolgreich
verteidigen und wir werden sie
unterstützen solange wie das
erforderlich ist
Putin hat geglaubt uns Europäer Spalten
zu können dort er hat das Gegenteil
erreicht
vor einigen Tagen beim Gründungstreffen
der europäischen politischen
Gemeinschaft haben sich 44 europäische
Staaten und die EU-Institutionen zu dem
Grundsatz bekannt das Grenzen nicht mit
Gewalt verändert werden dürfen
niemand von uns und auch kein anderes
zivilisiertes Land der Welt akzeptiert
die fadenscheinigen Versuche Russlands
sich Teile der Ukraine unter den Nagel
zu reißen die illegalen scheinreferenten
in donetts gluhanski waren eine einzige
Fass ihre Ergebnisse sind null und
nichtig
das müsste eigentlich auch die russische
Führung begreifen wenn sie sich das
Ergebnis der Abstimmung in der
Generalversammlung der Vereinten
Nationen letzte Woche anschaut
Nordkorea Syrien Nicaragua und Belarus
das waren die einzigen vier Länder die
mit Russland gestimmt haben
143 Staaten haben sich dagegen klar zur
Souveränität und zur territorialen
Integrität der Ukraine bekannt sogar
noch etwas mehr als bei den Abstimmungen
im März nach Ausbruch des Krieges
zugleich stellen sich viele die Frage
wie Putins irrsinniger Krieg beendet
werden könnte am meisten jedoch sehnen
sich wohl die Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
selbst nach Frieden
Präsident selenski ist Bereitschaft zu
einem gerechten Frieden ist daher kaum
hoch genug einzuschätzen im engen
Kontakt mit unseren Freunden in Kiew
haben wir als G7 erst vor wenigen Tagen
erklärt was es hierzu aus unserer Sicht
Bedarf gerecht bedeutet dass es sich
nicht um ein diktatfrieden handelt
sondern dass die Souveränität die
territoriale Integrität und auch die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit der Ukraine
gewährleistet sind heute und in Zukunft
unsere Bereitschaft der Ukraine mit
Blick auf eine tragfähige Friedenslösung
langfristige sicherheitszusage zu geben
haben wir ebenfalls als G7 erneut
bekräftigt
auch beim heute beginnenden Europäischen
Rat werden wir über die weitere
Unterstützung der Ukraine beraten die
gute Nachricht ist der Finanzbedarf Kias
bis Jahresende ist praktisch gedeckt die
EU und die G7 spielen dabei eine
entscheidende Rolle doch der Krieg und
seine Folgen werden uns noch auf viele
Jahre beschäftigen
umso wichtiger ist es dass wir heute
schon überlegen wie wir die Ukraine in
den kommenden Jahren beim Wiederaufbau
unterstützen wer die Bilder aus den von
Russland befreiten ukrainischen Städten
und Dörfern sieht der versteht
das wird eine Generationenaufgabe bei
der die gesamte zivilisierte
Staatengemeinschaft ihre Kräfte bündeln
muss
deshalb haben Ursula von der Leyen und
ich als Präsident der G7 der
wirtschaftsstarken Demokratien kluge
Köpfe aus Wissenschaft Wirtschaft und
Zivilgesellschaft für den 25 Oktober
nach Berlin eingeladen
bei einer internationalen
Expertenkonferenz wenn Sie Ihre
Vorschläge für einen langfristigen
verlässlichen und transparenten
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine zusammenführen
und so Input liefern für ein
internationalen Marshallplan für die
Ukraine
engere europäische und internationale
Koordinierung brauchen wir auch bei der
militärischen Unterstützung der Ukraine
diesen Vorschlag hatte ich bei meiner
Rede an der Prager Karls-Universität
Ente August gemacht seither ist diese
Idee weiter vorangekommen am Montag
haben sich die EU-Außenminister auf eine
neue ausbildungsmission für ca 15.000
ukrainische Soldaten und Soldaten hier
in der EU geeinigt eines der beiden
Hauptquartiere wird sich in Deutschland
befinden bis zum Frühjahr werden wir
eine vollständige Brigade mit bis zu
5.000 Soldaten ausbilden damit
unterstreichen wir unsere Bereitschaft
und dauerhaft am Aufbau starker
ukrainischer Streitkräfte zu beteiligen
Hand in Hand mit unseren Partnern
im Licht der zeitenwände stellen wir
auch unser Land sicherheitspolitisch neu
auf
dafür steht das Sondervermögen für die
Bundeswehr dafür steht die
Refokussierung unser Streitkräfte auf
die Landes- und bündnisverteidigung und
die Übernahme größerer Verantwortung an
der östlichen Flanke der Allianz dafür
steht die nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
an der wir intensiv arbeiten und dafür
stehen die Vorschläge zur
sicherheitszusammenarbeit in Europa die
ich in meiner Rede in Prag skizziert
habe
und ich freue mich dass die Idee einer
engeren europäischen Kooperation bei der
Luft Verteidigung so schnell von 14
europäischen Ländern aufgegriffen wurde
die dabei mit uns zusammenarbeiten
wollen das ist genau die Art von
seinergie die Art von
klugerarbeitsteilung wie wir sie für die
Sicherheit Europas jetzt brauchen
Russlands Krieg hat aber nicht nur
tiefgreifende Folgen für Europa weltweit
hat er für Engpässe bei Nahrungsmitteln
und Dunga gesorgt mit fatalen Folgen
830 Millionen mehr als jeder zehnte
Weltbürger hat laut aktuellen Zahlen
nicht genug zu essen
Putin nimmt das nicht nur in Kauf er
nutzt Hunger als Waffe
wir müssen uns auch diese
Bewährungsprobe stellen das ist eine
Frage der Humanität das ist aber auch
eine Frage der Glaubwürdigkeit
wenn wir wollen dass die Länder Afrikas
Asiens Lateinamerikas und der Karibik
uns auch künftig dabei unterstützen das
Völkerrecht gegen Aggressionen wie die
russische zu verteidigen dann ist es nur
recht und billig dass wir auch Ihre
Sorgen im Umgang mit den Folgen des
russischen Krieges ernst nehmen
in der Europäischen Union haben wir
dafür sehr früh damit begonnen
Alternative exportwege für ukrainisches
Getreide aufzubauen per Bahnen oder per
Schiff zum Beispiel über die Donau wir
haben die Vereinten Nationen und die
Türkei in den Verhandlungen über eine
Öffnung des Seewegs im Schwarzen Meer
unterstützt und wir greifen Ländern
weltweit unter die Arme die mit Hunger
Ernte Ausfällen und steigenden Preisen
für Brot und andere Grundnahrungsmittel
zu kämpfen haben
eines der zentralen Ziele unserer G7
Präsidentschaft war die Gründung eines
Bündnisses für globale
Ernährungssicherheit ich bin froh dass
uns das gelungen ist
und mit den diesjährigen Zusagen der G7
in Höhe von 14 Milliarden Dollar haben
wir zunächst zumindest eine Chance eine
globale
Hungerkatastrophe abzuwenden
meine Damen und Herren auch Energie
setzt putinen als bafaffe ein lange vor
der Zerstörung der nordstream Pipelines
in der Ostsee hat Russland bereits seine
Lieferung durch Nord Stream 1
eingestellt ohne nachvollziehbaren Grund
und deshalb
dieses Russland unter Putin ist kein
zuverlässiger Handelspartner mehr
für uns und für die gesamte Welt
bedeutet das auf dem Weltmarkt fehlt ein
Großteil der 150 55 Milliarden
Kubikmeter Gast die Russland zuletzt
durch Pipelines nach Europa geliefert
hat
Putin hat gehofft uns mit dem Abdrehen
des gasthahns erpressen zu können
doch auch da hat er sich verrechnet
denn Europa steht zusammen und auch wir
als Land haben mit den Maßnahmen der
vergangenen Wochen und Monate
sichergestellt dass wir voll Zuversicht
sagen können gemeinsam kommen wir wohl
durch diesen Winter
in Windeseile haben wir alternative
importstrukturen aufgebaut die ersten
flüssigkeits-terminals in Wilhelmshaven
Brunsbüttel gehen zum Jahreswechsel ans
Netz auch erste Lieferung über Lupinen
können dann möglicherweise erfolgen
weitere Terminals werden im Laufe des
kommenden Jahres hinzukommen
seit einer Woche fließt erstmals
überhaupt Gas aus Frankreich zu uns auch
die Kapazitäten an dem westeuropäischen
Häfen in den Niederlanden und Belgien
nutzen wir um zusätzliches Gast zu
beschaffen
verlässliche Partner wie Norwegen haben
Ihre Lieferung an uns erhöht mit den USA
und Ländern der arabischen Halbinsel
haben wir neue Lieferverträge
abgeschlossen weitere sind in
Vorbereitung
mit all diesen Maßnahmen haben wir
geschafft unsere Speicher in Deutschland
Europa rechtzeitig vor dem Winter zu
füllen anders als übrigens im Vorjahr
der den Füllstand von 95 Prozent den wir
in Deutschland zum ersten November
erreichen wollten haben wir schon
unterschritt überschritten das ist eine
große Leistung
wir haben entschieden dass wir
Kohlekraftwerke wieder ans Netz nehmen
erst in diesen Tagen sind fünf weitere
braunkohlekraftwerksblöcke in der
Lausitz und im Rheinischen Revier
hinzugekommen als zeitlich begrenzte
aber notwendige Notfallmaßnahme
Notfallmaßnahme denn wir stehen weiter
fest zu unseren erklärten Klimazielen
wir sorgen dafür dass wir alle drei noch
laufenden Atomkraftwerke den gesamten
Winterland nutzen können so hat es das
Kabinett gestern auf den Weg gebracht
und schließlich haben Unternehmen den
Umstieg von Gast auf andere
Energiequellen erleichtert für Switch
leitet das Stichwort
das alles steckt Deutschlands und
Europas Energiesicherheit
hinzu kommen die sparanstrengung vieler
Bürgern und Bürger und auch zahlreiche
Unternehmen ich bin dafür
außerordentlich dankbar
gemeinsam wollen wir unseren
gastverbrauch um 20% senken denn jede
Kilowattstunde die wir einsparen stärkt
unsere Energiesicherheit
und ich bin froh
und ich bin froh dass es uns gelungen
zur auf europäischer Ebene auf ein
einspazier von 15 Prozent beim
gastverbrauch zu einigen das ist ein
starkes Signal europäischer Solidarität
gerade auch gegenüber unserem Land das
bislang ganz besonders von russischem
Gas abhängig war
abhängig war wohlgemerkt denn wir haben
uns aus der Abhängigkeit befreit und
gehen zugleich gut vorbereitet in den
kommenden Winter
und noch etwas möchte ich erwähnen wenn
wir über Energiesicherheit reden unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden die Bundespolizei
die Dienste des Bundeskriminalamt das
BSI tun alles um gemeinsam mit den
Betreibern unsere kritischen
Infrastrukturen zu schützen auch mit den
Partnern in der NATO in der Europäischen
Union sind wir dazu in intensivem
Abstimmung mit Schweden und Dänemark
stimmen wir uns eng bei der Aufklärung
des sabotageakts gegen die beiden
nordstream Pipelines ab
auf sie zeigen Marine und Bundespolizei
mit allen verfügbaren Kräften und
Schiffen Präsenz und noch in diesem Jahr
wollen wir Eckpunkte beschließen für ein
dachgesetz zum besseren Schutz
kritischer Infrastruktur
wir wissen absolute Sicherheit kann es
angesichts der Größe und Komplexität
kritischer Infrastrukturen nicht geben
aber auch hier gilt wir sorgen vor und
vor allem wir lassen uns nicht
einschüchtern
meine Damen und Herren die
Energiesicherheit ist das eine die viel
zu hohen Energiepreise sind eine andere
große Bewährungsprobe für unser Land und
für Europa
keine Frage die Preise für Strom und
Wärme für Gas Öl und Kohle müssen runter
und zwar auf einen für die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und für unsere Unternehmen
verträgliches Maß auch das wird zu Recht
Thema sein beim Europäischen Rat heute
und morgen in Brüssel
wir haben beschlossen hier in
Deutschland eine strompreisbremse
einzuführen analog zu Entscheidungen auf
europäischer Ebene an der Umsetzung
arbeiten wir aktuell mit Hochdruck Ziel
ist Bürgern und Bürger so rasch wie
möglich für ein grundkontingent von
Strom zu entlasten
wir sind dabei den europäischen Weg
gegangen und haben in weniger Wochen
Mehrheiten in Europa zustande bekommen
das zeigt die EU ist in diesen Fragen
handlungsfähig und die Bundesregierung
wird immer darauf achten diese
europäische Handlungsfähigkeit zu
stärken
bei den Preisen für Gast und Wärme ist
das Ganze komplizierter denn der
Gaspreis wird von Knappheiten auf dem
Weltmarkt bestimmt
aber auch hier sind wir auf europäischer
Ebene schon weit gekommen so werden wir
beim Europäischen Rat heute darüber
sprechen unsere Nachfrage zu bündeln
ich bin der Europäischen Kommission
daher dankbar für Ihre Vorschläge
Einkaufsgemeinschaften europäischer
Unternehmen möglich zu machen die
gemeinsamen Gast kaufen können richtig
ist auch ein Teil der Kapazität der
europäischen gastspeicher im nächsten
Jahr gemeinsam zu befüllen mit dem
Modell Trading hat Europe haben wir
gezeigt wie das gehen kann
auch über die Entwicklung eines
ergänzenden gaspreisindexes zum TTF
werden wir uns Gedanken machen der
Bezugspunkt sein kann für künftige
gasimport Verträge
das beste Mittel
gegen ein zu knappes Angebot aber bleibt
der schnelle Ausbau der erneuerbaren
Energien die Kommission hat dazu bereits
Vorschläge für einfache
Planungsverfahren gemacht das sollte nun
auch für die großen Übertragungsnetze
geschehen auch dafür werde ich mich beim
Europäischen Rat stark machen
um die Ausfallenden russischen
gastliefern zu ersetzen müssen wir
außerdem mit Ländern zusammenarbeiten in
denen die Möglichkeit zu Erschließung
neuer gastfelder besteht natürlich im
Rahmen unserer Verpflichtung aus dem
Pariser Klimaabkommen
wir werden auch darüber sprechen wie wir
mit Preisspitzen umgehen die Vorschläge
der Kommission dazu schauen wir uns sehr
genau an
ein politisch gesetzter preisdecke wirkt
aber immer das Risiko dass die
Produzenten ihr Gast dann anderswo
verkaufen und wir Europäer am Ende nicht
mehr Gas bekommen sondern weniger
deshalb muss sich die EU mit anderen
gastkonsumenten etwa mit Japan und Korea
eng abstimmen damit wir uns nicht
gegenseitig Konkurrenz machen und
zugleich sprechen wir auch mit den
Produzenten über einen angemessenen
Preis
ich bin überzeugt Länder wie die USA
Kanada oder Norwegen die gemeinsam mit
uns solidarisch an der Seite der Ukraine
stehen haben ein Interesse daran dass
Energie in Europa nicht unbezahlbar wird
auch im g7-kreis sprechen wir darüber
schließlich wurde die G7
bzw damals noch die Gesetze als Antwort
auf die erste Ölkrise der 70er Jahre und
die Zusammenbruch des
brettenwutzssystems gegründet damals ist
es in diesem Rahmen gelungen die Welt
gemeinsam zurück auf einen Wachstumspfad
zu führen und das ist auch mein Ziel als
G7 Vorsitzender heute
parallel nutzen wir natürlich auch die
Möglichkeiten die wir als
Volkswirtschaft haben um die gast- und
Wärmepreise auf ein verträgliches Maß zu
senken dem dient der wirtschaftliche
abwirkschirm von bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro der unter anderem die
gaspreisbremse beinhaltet
eine Kommission aus Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftlern
arbeitgebervertretern Gewerkschaften
Stadtwerke und Energieversorgern hat uns
Anfang letzter Woche ein klugen
Vorschlag gemacht wie wir die
Preissteigerung für Gast und Fernwärme
stark begrenzen können
die vorgeschlagenen Maßnahmen haben
eines gemeinsam sie halten Energie
bezahlbar wirken schnell und Hebel
zugleich einspar-
wir setzen diesen Vorschlag nun um
spätestens im März nächsten Jahres
erhalten alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit
Gast oder Fernwärme ein vergünstigtes
basiskontingent und um schon früher für
Entlastung zu sorgen hat die Kommission
und empfohlen dass die Versorger das
Geld für Abschlagszahlung im Dezember
vom Staat erhalten auch Unternehmen
kleine und große werden gezielt
entlastet und deshalb können wir heute
sagen niemand keine Familie keine
Rentnerin kein Student und auch kein
Unternehmen soll Angst haben vor den
Preisen für Strom Gas- oder Fernwärme
überfordert zu werden
unseren Abwehrschirm haben wir bewusst
auf zweieinhalb Jahre angelegt um auch
für den nächsten Winter gewappnet zu
sein auf diesen Zeitraum gerechnet
entsprechen die 200 Milliarden Euro um
die zwei Prozent unseres
Bruttoinlandsprodukts das liegt in der
Größenordnung der Pakete die in diesem
Jahr auch anderswo in Europa geschnürt
wurden und werden in Frankreich in
Italien oder in Spanien zum Beispiel
die Europäische Union verfügt zudem über
genügend finanzielle Durchschlagskraft
um sich dieser Kriege entgegenzustellen
aus der Aufbau und resilienzfassilität
die wir während der corona-pandemie
gemeinsam beschlossen haben ist bislang
erst ein Fünftel ausgezahlt hier stehen
also noch über 600 Milliarden Euro zur
Verfügung die unsere Volkswirtschaften
stärken und für den Ausbau erneuerbarer
Energien genutzt werden können
dabei hilft uns auch die Einigung zur
Finanzierung von Repower EU die die
europäischen Finanzminister vor kurzem
erzielt haben damit wird ein
dreistelliger Milliardenbetrag aus den
Mitteln des Instruments next generation
EU genutzt und aufgestockt um uns
unabhängig zu machen von fossiler
Energie ich bin bereit zu schauen wie
wir diese und andere vorhandene Mittel
in der aktuellen Krise noch effizienter
einsetzen können
meine Damen und Herren diese europäische
Solidarität sorgt dafür dass die
Europäische Union Putins Energie
Erpressung standhält
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen eines
dürfen wir aber über all die
Bewährungsproben für die uns Putins
Angriffskrieg gestellt hat nicht aus den
Augen verlieren unser Ziel aus der
Nutzung fossiler Ressourcen auszusteigen
der schnelle Ausbau erneuerbare Energien
und der Netze sowie mehr
Energieeffizienz sind die beste
Strategie damit unsere Energieversorgung
sicher bleibt und wieder bezahlbar wird
jedes Windrad an Land oder auf See jede
Photovoltaikanlage macht uns ein Stück
unabhängiger von teurem Gast oder Öl
der Umbau des Energiesektors die
Transformation unserer Industrie die
Modernisierung unserer Gebäude der
Ausbau der Bahnung des Nahverkehrs der
Hochlauf der Elektromobilität und der
Wasserstoffwirtschaft das sind daher die
zentralen Aufgaben dieses Jahrzehnts
und die Weichen dafür sind gestellt wir
haben die umfassendste Novelle des EEG
des letzten Jahrzehnts verabschiedet wir
beschleunigen den Ausbau der Offshore
Windkraft im Februar kommenden Jahres
wird das Windenergie an Landgesetz in
Kraft treten das 2% der Fläche unseres
Landes für die Windkraft zur Verfügung
stellt noch im Herbst wollen wir ein
weiteres Paket zur
planungsbeschleunigung beschließen
denn was ich Anfang dieses Jahres
versprochen habe das halten wir ein alle
Regeln alle wichtigen Gesetze die es
braucht damit Deutschland seine
Klimaziele erreicht die stehen bis zum
Jahresende
auch auf EU-Ebene halten wir Kurs wir
wollen in den kommenden Monaten eine
endgültige Einigung auf das fit for
fifty five Paket herbeiführen als
Booster für den internationalen
Klimaschutz beim Anstehen der
Europäischen Rat werden wir unsere
Position für die anstehende
Weltklimakonferenz in Sharm el Sheikh
abstimmen die russische Aggression und
ihre Folgen dürfen nicht zu einer
weltweiten Renaissance der Kohle führen
deshalb werden wir klare Angebote machen
damit auch Entwicklungs- und
Schwellenländer den Weg in Richtung
eines klimaneutralen Energiesektors
geschlossen entschlossen gehen und wir
werden den Staaten entschlossen helfen
die schon heute besonders unter den
Folgen des Klimawandels leiden
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Bewährungsproben unserer Zeit erfordern
neues Denken und mutiges Handeln von
jedem von uns
im Eiltempo und oft unter größten
Handlungsdruck haben wir in den
vergangenen Monaten weitreichende
zukunftsweisende Entscheidung getroffen
für Europa für unser Land für seine
Bürgerinnen und Bürger
dabei haben wir miteinander immer wieder
um den besten Weg gerungen und werden
das auch weiterhin tun denn auch das ist
wichtig
in einer Autokratie wie Russland ist das
Ziel größtmögliche Uniformität
Kreativität und Widerspruch werden
bestraft mutige Oppositionelle
verschwinden auf Jahre in Gefängnissen
oder werden in den Ziel gezwungen nicht
zuletzt das Schicksal einiger der
diesjährigen Friedensnobelpreisträger
erinnert uns an diese Schande
in Demokratien wie unserer aber liefern
unsere Debatten liefern freie Medien und
öffentliche Kritik immer wieder Anstöße
für Veränderung und den Fortschritt
darin liegt die Stärke offener
Gesellschaften darin liegt die Kraft der
Demokratie
diese Kraft diese Stärke meine Damen und
Herren unterschätzen Putin und seine
Gefolgsleute auf dramatische Weise und
deshalb bin ich sicherer denn je
Putins Kriegskurs gegen die Ukraine und
die gesamte freie Welt wird scheitern
eigentlich ist es schon längst
die Ukraine Deutschland und Europa aber
werden gestärkt aus diesen
Bewährungsproben hervorgehen geeinter
und unabhängiger als zuvor schönen Dank
das war die Regierungserklärung des
Kanzlers wir sind stark seine Ansage an
Putin deutschlandliefere weiterhin
Waffen auch ein weiteres an die Ukraine
auch ein weiteres Stabilitätspaket der
EU sei die Folge
man werde die Ukraine unterstützen
solange es erforderlich ist den Bürgern
in Deutschland versprach Scholz dass man
gemeinsam durch diesen Winter komme wir
sorgen vor wir lassen uns nicht
einschüchtern so seine Botschaft die er
mehrfach wiederholte
nächster Redner wird nun Friedrich Merz
sein der Fraktionsvorsitzende der Union
ich eröffne nun die Aussprache und
zuerst hat das Wort für die
cdu/csu-fraktion Friedrich Merz
wow
Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren angesichts des russischen
Angriffskrieges gegen die Ukraine und
der folgen die dieser Krieg mittlerweile
auch für unser Land hat steht die
Europäische Union in diesen Wochen und
Monaten möglicherweise vor der größten
Bewährungsprobe ihrer Geschichte wir
können daher alle nur hoffen dass die 27
Staats- und Regierungschefs heute und
morgen in Brüssel zu guten und
tragfähigen Lösungen kommen Herr
Bundeskanzler wir wünschen Ihnen und
Ihren amtskolleginnen und Amtskollegen
in der Europäischen Union bei den
anstehenden Beratungen jeden möglichen
Erfolg
europa braucht diesen Erfolg
unser Land deutschland braucht diesen
Erfolg vor allem aber die Menschen die
privaten Haushalte und die vielen
Unternehmen die kleinen die mittleren
und die großen brauchen jetzt schnelle
und wirksame Hilfe
es sollte dabei auch klar sein welche
Aufgaben die Europäische Union übernimmt
was sie leisten kann und muss was Europa
jetzt ausdrücklich nicht tun sollte und
was zwingend in der Verantwortung und
der Zuständigkeit der Mitgliedstaaten
bleibt muss
lassen Sie mich dazu etwas ausführlicher
sprechen meine Damen und Herren die
notwendigen Sanktionen gegen Russland
und sie haben Bundeskanzler darüber
ausführlich gesprochen gehen nur
gemeinsam und ihr hat Europa in der Tat
in den letzten Wochen und Monaten eine
große Geschlossenheit und eine große
Entschlossenheit gezeigt Europa hat
diese Bewährungsprobe bestanden auch in
enger Abstimmung und Kooperation mit
anderen vor allem mit den Vereinigten
Staaten von Amerika
auch die finanziellen und humanitären
Hilfen für die Ukraine den
weitgehend jedenfalls nur gemeinsam auch
hier hat die Europäische Union
wirkungsvoll und zielführend geholfen
es wäre schließlich wünschenswert
gewesen meine Damen und Herren wenn auch
die militärische Hilfe für die
Europäische Union
europäisch abgestimmt und koordiniert
vorgenommen worden wäre und ich
wiederhole von dieser Stelle aus zum
wiederholten Male wir hätten es für
richtig gehalten wenn die Ukraine wenn
die ukrainische Armee auch mit
Schützenpanzern und Kampfpanzern
westlicher Bauart ausgestattet worden
wäre abgestimmt in der Europäischen
Union so wie viele Mitgliedstaaten es
befürworten
so wie eine große Zahl von Kolleginnen
und Kollegen insbesondere aus der grünen
Fraktion und aus der FDP-Fraktion ist
befürworten so wie wir es befürworten
dieser Krieg wäre dann möglicherweise
schneller zu Ende gewesen
und nun zu den Energiepreisen der
Bundeskanzler aus ihrer
Regierungserklärung können die zuhören
und Zuhörer heute morgen die Betroffenen
privaten Haushalte die Unternehmen in
Deutschland und darüber hinaus kaum
etwas Konkretes entnehmen wann ihnen
denn nun endlich geholfen wird
sie haben auch wenig und gar nichts
gesagt zum Arbeitsprogramm der
Kommission das gestern vorgelegt worden
ist meine Damen und Herren bei diesem
Arbeitsprogramm muss man den Eindruck
gewinnen als ob bis auf eine einzige
Ausnahme und das ist die sogenannte
Chemikalien Rechtsprechung oder
rechtssitzung bis auf eine Ausnahme in
allen anderen Bereichen in dieser
Europäischen Kommission der Apparat
weiter läuft und läuft und läuft und
jede Woche und jeden Monat neue
Richtlinien neue Verordnungen neue
Belastungen vor allem für die
Unternehmen in Europa auslöst meine
Damen und Herren das ist nein wir haben
Ihnen den konkreten Vorschlag gemacht
und sie haben es ja aufgenommen für das
nationale Programm ein
belastungsmoratorium warum sprechen Sie
nicht auch über ein belastungsmoratorium
jetzt in der Europäischen Union
warum lassen sie zu warum befördert ihre
Regierung dass auch in der Europäischen
Kommission von Woche zu Woche weitere
Vorschläge und Belastungen für die
Unternehmen gemacht werden bis hin zu
einer
csr-richtlinie die die Berichtspflichten
der Unternehmen gerade jetzt in dieser
Krise endgültig zu einem bürokratischen
Monstrum werden lassen wir brauchen
jetzt ein belastungsmoratorium für die
Unternehmen in der Europäischen Union
und damit auch in Deutschland
und dann bleiben tatsächlich zahlreiche
Aufgaben in der nationalen Verantwortung
meine Damen und Herren der Bundeskanzler
sie fahren in dieser Hinsicht morgen
heute und morgen nach Brüssel nicht
gerade mit gutem Vorbild im Gegenteil
Deutschland dürfte in Brüssel bewertet
werden als das Land in Europa dessen
Regierung in den letzten Monaten am
heftigsten gestritten und mit am
wenigsten erreicht hat bei der
Entlastung der privaten Haushalte und
der Unternehmen
dieser Krieg
dauert in wenigen Tagen jetzt acht
Monate und wenn man hört was sie auch
auf verbandstagungen gerade vor wenigen
Tagen hier in Berlin gesagt haben dann
wissen Sie ja schon sehr viel länger
welche Folgen dieser Krieg
möglicherweise haben kann sie haben hier
in Berlin vor wenigen Tagen gesagt ich
war mir immer sicher dass er putin war
gemeint das tun würde nämlich Energie
als Waffe einzusetzen und dann sagen Sie
das war glaube ich zu einer Zeit als die
allermeisten das nicht für
wahrscheinlich gehalten haben aber ich
habe es für möglich gehalten sie nehmen
Bezug auf eine Besprechung mit
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern im
Bundeskanzleramt im dezember 2021 ich
war mir immer sicher dass er das tun
würde Herr Bundeskanzler wenn sie sich
im dezember 2021 schon sicher waren dass
er das tun würde warum haben sie dann
eigentlich bis die Kriegsbeginn an
nordstream 2 festgehalten und das zu
einem privatwirtschaftlichen Projekt
erklärt und warum haben Sie eigentlich
von dieser klugen Erkenntnis nicht ihre
Kolleginnen und Kollegen in der
Europäischen Union in kenntnisgesetz
dass man schon im Dezember 2021 hätte an
Maßnahmen denken müssen zur Bewältigung
dieser Krise
sie haben zu Beginn sie haben zu Beginn
ihrer
Regierungserklärung klausewitz zitiert
Herr Bundeskanzler von Clausewitz stammt
auch der schöne Satz aus dem Wissen muss
ein können umgekehrte das hätten wir von
Ihnen auch erwartet
sie haben sie haben eine
gaskommission um Vorschläge gebeten zur
Dämpfung der Gaspreise und zur Lösung
dieses Problems diese Vorschläge liegen
nun seit Anfang der letzten Woche vor
wir haben zwei Sitzungswochen des
Deutschen Bundestages in dieser und in
der letzten sie haben nicht einen
einzigen Vorschlag unterbreitet heute
welche Schlussfolgerungen denn aus
dieser gaskommission gezogen werden
sollen zur Lösung des Problems bei der
Gasbeschaffung und bei den Gaspreisen
es bleibt es bleibt völlig offen was
denn diejenigen privaten Haushalte die
noch mit Öl heizen oder die zum Beispiel
gerade frisch angeschafft haben eine
Pelletheizung wie diese halt wie dieser
Haushalte denn konkret entlastet werden
sollen damit kein Missverständnis
entsteht wir befürworten hier
weitestgehend gemeinsame europäische
Wege aber es gibt Verantwortungen im
nationalen Zusammenhang der sie
nachkommen müssen und die die
Europäische Union überhaupt nicht
übernehmen kann diese Fragen gehören
dazu und diese Fragen bedürfen der
Beantwortung im Deutschen Bundestag und
nicht auf der Ebene des Europäischen
Rates
und wenn sie jetzt als einziges Datum
nennen wo die privaten Haushalte und die
Unternehmen Entlastung erwarten dürfen
das Frühjahr 2023 dann kann ich Ihnen
nur sagen der Bundeskanzler Winterreifen
muss man im Oktober aufziehen und nicht
erst im Frühjahr des nächsten Jahres
jetzt brauchen die Menschen und die
Unternehmen in Deutschland eine klare
Perspektive jetzt brauchen die Menschen
und die Unternehmen in Deutschland eine
klare Antwort wann sie möglichst bald in
den nächsten Tagen und Wochen mit
konkreter Entlastung rechnen dürfen und
deswegen will ich abschließend sagen die
besten Beschlüsse in Brüssel
bewirken überhaupt nichts wenn die
Bundesregierung in Deutschland nicht
schnell zur wirksamen Entlastungen kommt
für private Haushalte und für die
Unternehmen von denen die meisten nicht
mehr lange Zeit haben herzlichen Dank
er fordert schnelle und wirksame Hilfen
für Unternehmen und Bürger wann den
BürgerInnen konkret geholfen werden dazu
habe Scholz heute nichts gesagt ebenso
wenig wie Bürger die eine Öl oder
Pelletheizung haben wie denen geholfen
werden soll auch auf EU-Ebene werde zu
wenig getan für die Unternehmen in der
Krise
nächste Rednerin nun Britta Hasselmann
Fraktionsvorsitzende von Bündnis 90
Hunde
nächste Rednerin für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Britta Hasselmann
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren von diesem
Gipfeltreffen muss ein Signal der
Geschlossenheit ausgehen und ich bin mir
sicher dass wir das auch
Geschlossenheit um unser gemeinsames
Vorgehen bei den sanktionspaketen bei
den finanziellen
humanitären und bei der militärischen
Unterstützung
deutlich zu machen zu unterstreichen und
klarzumachen dass sie das schärfste
Schwert sind gegen Putin europäische
Geschlossenheit die Geschlossenheit der
7 und der internationalen
Staatengemeinschaft sind in dieser Krise
das wichtigste von was wir haben meine
Damen und
gleichzeitig werden hoffentlich und
davon bin ich davon gehen wir aus ganz
klare Signale ausgehen
europäische und nationale Maßnahmen
gegen hohe Energiepreise werden Hand in
Hand gehen dafür machen wir uns stark
der gemeinsame Einkauf von Gas die
Senkung des Verbrauchs und die
versifizierung von Energiequellen durch
erneuerbare ein Booster für erneuerbare
Energien und auch einer übergewinnsteuer
die zur Veränderung sozialer Härten in
den Nationalstaaten und europäisch in
der unterschiedlichen Lage der Staaten
dient das werden gemeinsame Botschaften
sein und Aufträge die wir uns wechselt
seitlich erteilen und das ist gut und
wichtig so dass dieses Signal aus Europa
ausgehen wird beim Europäischen Rat
meine Damen und Herren wir verurteilen
die jüngsten massiven Angriffe auf die
Zivilbevölkerung auf die zivile
Infrastruktur in der Ukraine die
Mobilisierung in Russland die Allianz
mit was Russland die völkerrechtswidrige
Annexion der besetzten Gebiete die
Angriffe auf so viele unschuldige
Menschen all das zeigt die wahnsinnige
Irrationalität dieses brutalen
Angriffskrieges und das zeigt auch dass
Putin immer mehr in Bedrängnis gerät
weil er führt den Krieg jetzt so gegen
die Menschen die Zivilbevölkerung und es
trifft sie alle so grausam und hart es
ist brutal das bereitet mir und uns
große Sorgen gestern nun noch die
Verhängung des Kriegsrechts in den
sogenannten annektierten Gebieten hier
sollen neue Spannungen geschürt werden
ein vermeintlicher Angriff auch der
Ukraine auch vermeintlich russisches
Territorium dabei ist doch klar es gibt
kein russisches Kriegsrecht auf
ukrainischem Territorium meine Damen und
Herren
1100 ukrainische Orte Siedlung Dörfer
sind ohne Strom Angriffe auf Wohnhäuser
auf Krankenhäuser auf
Versorgungseinrichtungen auf Spielplätze
die
Zivilbevölkerung soll in Angst und
Schrecken versetzt werden die Menschen
leiden in dieser Situation unglaublich
und deshalb ist jede Kraftanstrengung
nötig und deshalb dürfen wir auch nicht
nachlassen in unserem Engagement
humanitär wirtschaftlich für den
Wiederaufbau für die Frage der
Beitrittsperspektive der EU und auch was
die Waffenlieferungen angeht meine Damen
und Herren jeden Tag müssen wir uns
fragen tun wir genug und was können wir
noch leisten dass es unsere Aufgabe im
europäischen Verbund
und meine Damen und Herren werden hier
einerseits die Solidarität mit der
Ukraine einfordert und mehr Solidarität
einfordert Herr Merz ich will Ihnen an
dieser Stelle sagen ich habe es an
anderer schon getan es hat wehgetan
wirklich vegetan und geschmerzt und ihre
halbseidene Entschuldigung hat daran
nichts geändert dass sie in dieser
schrecklichen Situation sich so
abwertend und populistisch gegenüber
geflüchteten Menschen in der Ukraine
geäußert haben
und es ist unverzeihlich
denn kurz nach ihrer Entschuldigung
wurde weiter nachgelegt in diesem Thema
und ich finde sie sollten das überdenken
denn wir haben hier alle eine große
Verantwortung gegenüber den Menschen die
noch in der Ukraine sind und dort in
ihrem Land bleiben und kämpfen und
gegenüber denen die hier sind und sich
nicht sehnlicher wünschen wieder
zurückzugehen in ihrer Heimat die Suppe
droht ist und deshalb lassen Sie die
Finger davon mit dieser Methode
Populismus in dieser Art und Weise zu
arbeiten meine Damen und Herren und
wieder
und wieder haben wir gerade die
den Vorwurf gehört jetzt handelt mal
endlich
wo sind sie eigentlich in dieser
Situation wo sind sie in ihrer
Verantwortung in der größten Krise
dieses Landes und der größten Krise
Europas sich nicht in fundamental
Opposition zu verkriechen sondern
Verantwortung zu übernehmen meine Damen
und Herren
und jetzt mal kurz zum Thema diese
Regierung handelt nicht
meine Damen und Herren wir haben zwei
entlastungspakete auf den Weg gebracht
zur sozialen Abfederung die sind für
Menschen für Handwerk für Wirtschaft
eine Unterstützung und da können Sie 100
mal sagen es ist nicht der Fall es wirkt
wenn
energiepreisbremse wenn
Unterstützungsleistungen für
Rentnerinnen und Rentner für Studierende
wenn die Frage der Grundsicherung erhöht
wird und und und und und das sind alles
Maßnahmen die gezielt abfedern sollen
die sozialen Härten in diesem Land und
das ist gut und wichtig so
seit Milliarden Abwehrschirm der gerade
geplant wird sie sollten nicht einfach
nur sagen das läuft nicht gut machen Sie
doch mal einen Vorschlag wo sind sie
denn da Griechen in ihren Löchern und
erklären jeden Tag wir würden nicht
handeln und weil sie da vielleicht eine
kleine Stütze brauchen sage ich Ihnen
mal kurz was diese Bundesregierung
gemeinsam mit Robert Habeck ihm
Verantwortlichen Ministerium und den
anderen minister:innen auf den Weg
gebracht hat die Verpflichtung zu
befüllen der gaspeicher die Forcierung
des Netzausbaus der Ausbau der Wind
Energie der schnellere Ausbau der
lng-terminals der wasserstoffausgleich
die Anpassung der Ausschreibungen für
Wind und Solar die
effizienz-standards das
Energieeffizienzgesetz die
Abstandsregeln aufheben die alle lange
die windenergieausbau Sachen blockiert
haben dass erneuerbare Grundgesetz das
Energiewirtschaftsgesetz das
bundesbedarfsplanungsgesetz und
zahlreiche Verordnungen ich weiß es tut
ihnen weh wenn man das aufzählt weil
dann zeigt sich damit das konkret
gehandelt wird meine Damen und Herren
und darum geht es in dieser Krise
genau darum geht es in dieser Krise und
ich erwarte von ihnen dass sie
Verantwortung übernehmen und sie
konstruktiv in diese
Lösungssuche einbringen meine Damen und
Herren wir sind in einer schweren Krise
und dass das notwendig und lassen Sie
mich zuletzt doch sagen als bitte und
zugleich als Aufforderung denn wir
wissen was die fossile Abhängigkeit
Russlands für unser Land in dieser Krise
bedeutet wir haben in den vergangenen
Monaten gesehen was das bedeutet und wir
sollten wenn wir über China diskutieren
dringend berücksichtigen was uns die
fossile Abhängigkeit und die zementierte
Abhängigkeit von Russland gekostet hat
keine Fehler in Bezug auf die
China-Politik meine Damen und Herren das
ist notwendig und da steht jetzt an
klare deutliche Worte der Grünen
Fraktionsvorsitzenden dass diese
Regierung nicht genug tue wie es die
Opposition behauptet wie sie in aller
Deutlichkeit zurück Hasselmann betonte
wie wichtig die Geschlossenheit der EU
sei in diesen Zeiten gemeinsamer
Gaseinkauf ein Booster für die
Erneuerbaren dieses Signal müsse vom
EU-Gipfel ausgehen es folgt Tino propala
Fraktionsvorsitzender der AFD
heute lassen Sie mich
vorab den Zweige töteten Handwerkern in
Ludwigshafen gedenken die vor zwei Tagen
von einem Somalia ermordet wurden Frau
Hasselmann das schmerzt ich wünsche den
Familien und Hinterbliebenen viel Kraft
ich wünsche den verletzten schnelle
Genesung
und auch das ist mittlerweile Normalität
in Deutschland kommen wir zum
Europäischen Rat der heute und morgen in
Brüssel zusammentritt um den Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine und seine
Auswirkungen auf die Energiekrise und
die Wirtschaften Europa behandelt so ist
ja auch der Titel einerseits scheint die
Brisanz einer Energiekrise in den Köpfen
angekommen zu sein andererseits
verwechselt man hier wieder Ursache und
Wirkung eine Antwort auf die Krise soll
jedenfalls der sogenannte
gaspreisdeckel sein so hören wir es und
so lesen wir es jedoch bleiben hier mehr
Fragen offen kann die Energie und
Versorgungssicherheit Deutschlands
garantiert werden kaufen wir gemeinsam
in ausreichender Menge ein wie wird der
Verteilschlüssel sein nach Bedarf wie
viel mehr kostet dem Steuerzahler die
gemeinsame Beschaffung im Vergleich zur
nationalen Beschaffung dazu gab es heute
vom Bundeskanzler keine Antworten
gemeinsam mit den europäischen Staaten
die Energieversorgung sicherzustellen
kann ein Weg sein wenn Deutschland nicht
mehr investieren muss und mit allen
europäischen part im guten Kontakt und
nicht teilweise im Krieg stehen würde
der Kontinent Europa verfügt über
ausreichend Energie-
dafür braucht es aber eine Infrastruktur
die durch die Gemeinschaft auch
gesichert wird und in diesem zusammen
Hang ist sie Herr Bundeskanzler wo sie
die Untersuchungsergebnisse zur Sabotage
an Nordstemmen 1 und 2 wo die Ergebnisse
sind die habe ich schon vor einer Woche
gefragt sie haben noch in der letzten
Woche gesagt dass diese bald vorliegen
werden nun weigert sich Schweden uns
untersuchungsdetails zu nennen und da
frage ich sie entspricht das einem
vertrauensvollen Umgang innerhalb der
Europäischen Gemeinschaft gehen so
Freunde mit uns um
wir hatten und wir haben mit den
nordstream Pipelines die Möglichkeit als
Deutschland zu berälen und preiswert
unsere Energieversorgung sicherzustellen
und ebenso könnten darüber Teile Europas
auch bedient werden wir haben immer
dafür geworben dass ich die deutsche
Bundesregierung Optionen offen halten
muss Optionen um selbst handlungsfähig
zu bleiben damit der Wohlstand der
Wirtschaft der Industrie und damit der
Bevölkerung gesichert wird alles das
setzen sie mit ihren selbst entfachten
Wirtschaftskrieg der sich hauptsächlich
gegen uns gegen unsere Bevölkerung
richtet auf Spiel ihre Maßnahmen und
Hilfsprogramme kommen spät und sind
immer wieder schlechte Kompromisse die
in erster Linie den Bürger langfristig
nur Kosten verursachen denn auch die 200
Milliarden neues Sondervermögen sind
neue Schulden die am Ende der
Steuerzahler sowieso bezahlen muss das
ist das übliche Spiel linke Tasche
rechte Tasche und die sind oben drei zum
Teil verfassungswidrig wie ist der
Bundesrechnungshof bereits schon
angekündigt hat und ich habe schon oft
gesagt sie hantieren ungeschickt und
lockt dann an den Symptomen herum
anstelle sich den Ursachen endlich zu
widmen und diese liegen aktuell in ihrer
Politik der Sanktionen daran scheinen
sie wirklich mittlerweile gefallen zu
entwickeln schauen Sie mal durch die
wertebrille Frau beerbock welches ist
das nächste Land von dem sich
distanzieren wollen sie gehen ja da
schon eifrig voran es ist schon wirklich
eigenartig dass gerade aus der Partei
die einmal für Offenheit und tolerant
stand nun die größten Oberlehrer kommen
diese würden zur Durchsetzung ihrer
sogenannten Werte mittlerweile auch
Waffen sprechen lassen wollen
Diplomatie ebenfalls gehört nicht zu
ihrer Stärke das beweisen sie gerade in
den Reihen der Ampelkoalition bei den
Bürgern arbeiten sich immer weniger
Respekt und Glaubwürdigkeit das sieht
man ja nicht nur in den
Umfrageergebnissen der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister bescheinigt
zudem die Erfolge einer eigenen Politik
Tag für Tag wenn er von Höchstpreisen
für Energie einer kommenden Rezession
und den Niedergang der deutschen
Wirtschaft spricht und da muss man sagen
die Politik von Robert Habeck wirkt sie
sorgen nämlich dafür aktiv dass wir zu
einem Schwellenland oder zum Sorgenkind
Europas werden und Sie sollten wirklich
und das sollte ich wirklich Arabic sich
mal überlegen darüber nachdenken ob sie
ihr Amt noch zum Wohle des deutschen
Volkes ausfüllen oder sich besser wieder
in die Welt der Fabelwesen zurückziehen
sollte
zum Bundeswirtschaftsminister
zum Bundesfinanzminister Herr Linder sie
sprachen in Dresden vor jung Handwerks
meistern und ich zitiere wo sie noch sie
erinnern sich Witze über ihren Kollegen
Lauterbach und Habeck machten vor
wenigen Wochen haben sie das dort den
jungen Handwerksmeister gesagt ich
zitiere wir müssen all das tun was
Energiepreise runterbringt und all das
unterlassen was Energiepreise steigen
lässt in einer solchen Situation muss
man alle Kapazitäten die verfügbar sind
am Netz behalten
allerdings über Ostern hinaus und er in
Dresden erzählen sie das den Leuten was
sie dort hören wollen und hier in Berlin
machen sie genau das Gegenteil mit ihrer
Politik das ist die verlogene Politik
der FDP das ist die verlogene Politik
gegen Handwerk und gegen Mittelstand und
das haben die Wähler in Niedersachsen
bereits erkannt
und da kann ich Ihnen nur sagen lieber
Herr Linda lügen haben kurze Beine und
deshalb sollten sich wirklich warme
Unterwäsche besorgen dann ist es bei
Bodenfrost
das Grundverhältnis von Angebot und
Nachfrage ebenfalls haben sie noch nicht
erkannt und es ist immer noch vorhanden
und dabei ist gerade das Angebot auf dem
Energiemarkt weiterhin stabil nur sie
verändern Werte Bundesregierung durch
ihre aggressive Sanktionspolitik den
Zugriff auf den Markt und reduzieren das
Angebot sie entscheiden nämlich
plötzlich nicht mehr bei jedem Anbieter
zu kaufen
und möchten von denen die mit
Deutschland noch Geschäfte machen
Produkte kaufen die sie gar nicht mehr
im Angebot haben das ist die Realität
und so verknappen sie selbst das
Energieangebot das beste Beispiel sind
dafür sind die Verhandlungen mit
Saudi-Arabien oder auch Kanada mit einem
Lächeln Kern sie nach Hause zurück und
müssen anschließend immer wieder
feststellen dass die sogenannten
Lieferanten von LNG Gas überhaupt kein
adäquates Angebot für uns haben und da
sehen sie es wieder was wir immer sagen
in der Politik geht es nämlich um
Interessen herr Scholz und nicht nur um
Freundschaften das ist die Realität
meine Damen und Herren auf der
Regierungsbank machen sie sich endlich
ehrlich und gestehen sich selbst ein
dass ihr Konzept der Energiewende nicht
trägt und die Energiewende ist
gescheitert und auch Sie Herr Merz
sollten das endlich realisieren Ihr
stellvertretender Bundesvorsitzender aus
Sachsen hat es bereits getan und sie
sind mitverantwortlich sie sind
mitverantwortlich dass diese
Energiewende gescheitert ist denn sie
haben die Atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet
das sollen wir nicht vergessen
und die schädigen nachhaltig auch die
CDU was Generationen vor uns mühevoll
errichtet haben und alles nur um ihre
ideologischen Leitlinien zu erfüllen
eine gesunde Umwelt ist die
Lebensgrundlage für alle Menschen und
zukünftigen Generationen darüber sind
wir uns ja hier in diesem Haus einig wie
wir dieses Ziel Sozial- und
wirtschaftlich verträglich erreichen
wollen das ist jedoch die Frage und
deshalb brauchen wir im Bereich der
Energieversorgung Optionen jedoch sind
in Deutschland eine Unmenge an
Windrädern und unkonventionelle
Erdgasförderung ebenso wenig eine Option
wie die endlose Förderung von Braunkohle
ja auch die ist endlich das wissen wir
wir brauchen einen gesunden Energie-Mix
der bezahlbar und vor allen Dingen
grundlastfähig ist und gerade in einem
Industrieland wie Deutschland kann man
nicht regelbare grundlastfähige Energie
wie Kohle Kernenergie und Gas durch
volatile Energie wie Wind und Sonne
ersetzen
und wer der Grünen Fraktionen dazu
braucht man nicht mal einen Studien oder
Berufsabschluss das ist einfach gesunder
Menschenverstand
sie möchten mit allen unmöglichen
Mitteln das westliche Werte und
Wirtschaftssystem retten und sind dabei
die Kommandeure des eigenen Niedergangs
aber gerade wir in Europa müssen doch
Interessen geleitete Politik für unsere
Bürger machen der Kontinent Europa hat
einen festen Platz in einer multipolaren
Weltordnung dafür brauchen wir Frieden
Stabilität und vor allen Dingen
wirtschaftliche Souveränität sie und
ihre einseitige US-amerikanische
Ausrichtung sind die Totengräber der
deutschen Wirtschaften das sehen wir
jeden Tag
kommen Sie bitte zum Wohle des Volkes
zur Vernunft versuchen sie endlich ihre
ideologischen Interessen zurückzustellen
im Moment verpokern sie alles Kapital
zugunsten einseitiger transatlantischer
Bündnisse bzw neuer Abhängigkeiten
Deutschland jedenfalls nutzt ihre
Politik nichts sie spalten damit nicht
nur Europa sondern auch die
Weltgemeinschaft noch eben sicher
geglaubte Wirtschaftspartner werden sich
ab und suchen sich neue Kontakte wie zum
Beispiel Saudi-Arabien und seinem Plan
den brix-staaten beizutreten und deshalb
fordere ich Sie für die Glaubwürdigkeit
gegenüber unseren europäischen Partnern
auch bei diesen Gipfel auf erstens
sorgen Sie schnellstmöglich dafür dass
die drei stillgelegten und die drei
aktiv verbliebenen Kernkraftwerke über
den April 23 hinaus die
Energieversorgung sichern dafür braucht
dies jetzt auch neue Brennelemente
und im übrigen wäre das genau die Stunde
des Parlaments wir fordern eine offene
von den Fraktionen nicht beeinflusste
Abstimmung namentlich denn hier geht es
um Verantwortung jeder Abgeordnete soll
das in seinem Wahlkreis erklären auch
diejenigen die sich der Realität
verweigern das ist Demokratie und das
fordern wir
zweitens klären Sie die
sabotageanschläge auf die
nordstream-leitungen auf sorgen Sie
dafür dass die kritischen Infrastruktur
auch geschützt wird und geschützt ist
dass durch die Pipelines auch wieder Gas
nach Deutschland und Europa geliefert
wird und drittens beenden Sie Ihre Werte
geleitete Sanktionspolitik und stoppen
Sie die Waffenlieferung an die Ukraine
helfen sie den Krieg in Europa durch
Verhandlungen zu beenden und hören Sie
auf Moral und Sittenpolizei hören sie
auf Moral und Sittenpolizei auf der
ganzen Welt zu spielen Herr lambsdorf
agieren sie endlich souverän zum Wohle
unseres Landes und zum Wohle unserer
deutschen Bürger
vielen Dank das war Tino cupalla von der
AFD mit heftigen Vorwürfen wegen über
der Regierung die Energiewende sei
gescheitert sie seien die Totengräber
der deutschen Wirtschaft erfordert das
Nord Stream 1 und 2 offen gehalten
werden nächster Redner Christian dürr
Fraktionschef der FDP
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin verehrte Kollegen
Kollegen Europa
bleibt geprägt durch den russischen
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine die
Verbrechen gegen die Bevölkerung die
täglichen Menschenrechtsverletzung das
bewusste und willkürliche Töten von
Zivilisten von Menschen Familien das
geht weiter dieser Tage der russische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine gehört
leider zum Alltag der Menschen in der
Ukraine doch er darf niemals etwas
Alltägliches werden meine Damen und
Herren die russische
die russische Strategie hat sich ja
dieser Tage geändert das wird deutlich
30% des Stromnetzes sind zerstört und
mittlerweile über 1.000 Orte ohne
Stromversorgung russland zeigt dass es
auf stumpfe Zerstörung aus ist die
Terrorisierung der Menschen in der
Ukraine ist das strategische Ziel Putins
und herru parlam
eigentlich wollte ich nicht auf diese
absurde Rede eingehen aber es ist
notwendig denn das was sie hier
betreiben ist täteropferumkehr es ist
übrigens die Empfehlung dass sich
Deutschland aus der westlichen
Staatengemeinschaft verabschiedet wie
absurd es ist nicht im nationalen
Interesse was ihr sagen das was sie
sagen richtet sich auch gegen
Deutschland es ist absurd so etwas
hierzu überhaupt der Opalla der
Aggressor sitzt im Kreml sind ihre
Freunde im Kreml die diese Menschen
angreifen und terrorisieren
und ich sage das deshalb weil sie von
aggressiver Sanktionspolitik gesprochen
haben aggressiver Sanktionspolitik ich
habe gerade von den Terroraktionen
Putins gegen Menschen der Ukraine
gesprochen Herr Kollege rupalla liebe
Kollegen der AFD hören sie auf so etwas
zu sagen ich will hier eines aussprechen
das was sie anempfehlen ist das dieses
große Land das sich Deutschland aus dem
Westen verabschiedet das darf niemals
Politik in Deutschland sein gerade nach
den Erfahrungen des Zweiten Weltkrieges
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn das Ziel
das Ziel Putins ist es die Ukraine zu
zerstören damit es sich nicht mehr lohnt
über einen danach zu reden und Herr
Bundeskanzler ich bin Ihnen dankbar dass
sie genau über dieses danach gesprochen
haben das müssen wir bereits heute trotz
der schrecklichen Bilder tun wir müssen
über einen europäischen Maßstab Plan für
die Ukraine reden und ein erster ganz
wichtiger Schritt ist die
wiederaufbaukonferenz am 25.10 hier in
Berlin wir wollen die Ukraine beim
Wiederaufbau unterstützen das wollen wir
bereits heute in aller Klarheit sagen
genauso wie wir die Ukraine bei ihren
Weg nach Europa unterstützen liebe
Kollegen Kollegen und ich will direkt
jetzt natürlich auf die Auswirkungen auf
Deutschland auf die Menschen in
Deutschland und unsere Wirtschaft zu
sprechen kommen Deutschland Europa
befinden sich aktuell in einem
energiekrisenmodus deshalb ist es so
wichtig zu betonen dass die Bekämpfung
der Inflation und der hohen
Energiepreise natürlich für uns alle
höchste Priorität hat und wir wollen
vermeiden dass es zu strukturbrüchen
kommt wir müssen uns in Europa auf
unsere großen Stärken deshalb besinnen
unsere wirtschaftliche Stärke die
Solidarität und Geschlossenheit der
Europäischen Union und auf Demokratie
und Freiheit und Herr Kollege
Entschuldigung gestatten sie eine
Zwischenfrage oder Zwischenbemerkung aus
der afd-fraktion
ja
ich neige normalerweise nicht dazu aber
ich finde die dürfen sich auch
öffentlich lächerlich machen
Kollege bistron sie haben das Wort ja
vielen Dank Kollege dürr ist ja auch in
so einer Ärztin ernsten Situationen noch
ihren Humor bewarnt das ist gut sie
haben ausgeführt dass der Aggressor in
Moskau sitzt das stimmt
russland hat die Ukraine angegriffen
nicht Deutschland und wenn sie sagen wir
sind als ein Teil Westens und wir dürfen
uns davon nicht verabschieden das ist
auch richtig aber ein Teil des Westens
waren wir schon immer und es war eine
gute deutsche Außenpolitik übrigens
liberale und sozialdiberale Koalition
haben sie betrieben die auf Versöhnung
ausgerichtet war auf Diplomatie nicht
auf Eskalation und es waren liberale
Außenminister die sich für Dialog
eingesetzt haben und nichts anderes
fordern wir von der von der AFD
[Applaus]
und wir hatten hier diese Woche gerade
einer Expertenanhörung die uns bestätigt
haben dass die USA einen aggressiven
Wirtschaftskrieg betreiben die ziehen
gerade Schlüsselindustrien in die USA
ist es werden Firmen hier in Deutschland
machen wir gehen pleite andere Firmen
wandern in die USA ab also bitte öffnen
sie die Augen sehen Sie das ganz
deutlich dass ihr transatlantischer
Partner auf unsere Kosten Politik
betreibt und Wettbewerber vom Markt
verdrängt und Firmen zu sich nach Hause
holt und davor warnen wir sie das war
der der Schlüssel der die Kernaussage
der Rede von unserem Vorsitzenden also
verkennen Sie das bitte nicht
also ich will eins betont viel Dank Frau
Präsident wenn ich Antworten darf auf
diese Frage das ist nicht mein
transatlantischer Partner sondern seit
vielen Jahrzehnten unser
transatlantischer Partner die
Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika den
Frieden nach Deutschland gebracht haben
die den Frieden nach Deutschland
gebracht haben und der tiefere Sinn wenn
ich es so sagen nach Ihrer Frage und die
tiefere These lautet ja wie folgt und
deswegen bin ich dankbar dass wir das
hier einmal ansprechen dürfen die Tiere
these dahinter lautet ja man dürfe nicht
Waffen die von dir Vorsitzender als hier
gerade erklärt sondern man müsste reden
niemand in der Ukraine niemand hier
kommt doch auf die Idee zu sagen wir
würden uns nicht bereits heute Nacht
wünschen dass Frieden in der Ukraine
herrschen und das ist genau das was ich
mit täteropfer Umkehr meine Herr Kollege
natürlich wollen wir Frieden so schnell
wie möglich dort sterben Menschen dort
sterben jeden Tag Kinder und Familien
liebe Kollegen Kollegen es ist doch
Wladimir Putin der nicht über Frieden
reden will sondern kampfdrohen nach Kiew
geschickt hat das ist doch die Wahrheit
liebe Kollegen Kolleg und das Recht der
Ukraine sich zu verteidigen ist
abzusprechen indem wir Waffenlieferung
einstellen das wäre die wahre und
Menschlichkeit in diesem Konflikt vielen
Dank dass ich das an der Stelle war noch
einmal darstellen durfte ich will jetzt
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen auf die Europäische Union und
das was wir energiepolitisch
richtigerweise tun können und machen
sollten zu sprechen kommen und Herr
Kollege Merz sie haben ein wie ich finde
richtigen Punkt angesprochen den ja die
Bundesregierung die regierungstragenden
Fraktion bereits im Abwehr für die
deutsche Wirtschaft für unser Land für
die privaten Haushalte mit verankert
haben nämlich ein belastungsmoratorium
es war auch ein wichtiger Wunsch meiner
Partei Herr Kollege Merz ich teile Ihre
Einschätzung dass das auf europäischer
Ebene auch der Fall sein sollte ich will
es mal etwas entschuldigen Sie die
Wortwahl über spitz sagen es gibt
Wahlkämpfe der CDU die nicht erfolgreich
waren oder nach einem CDU-Mitglieder auf
ihre Autos den Aufkleber gemacht meckert
nicht ich habe CDU gewählt ich will
Ihnen antworten bei der Europawahl MEC
hat nicht ich habe FDP gewählt ich würde
mir wünschen dass die
cdu-kommissionspräsidentin das was sie
hier richtigerweise vorschlagen und ich
hoffe sie haben ihre Nummer das was sie
hier richtigerweise vorschlagen auch zur
Politik der Europäischen Kommission
macht sie haben uns voll an ihrer Seite
das ist aber keine Frage die hier zu
entscheiden ist sondern die
cdu-kommissionspräsident sollte diesen
Weg gehen wenn wir das zusammen machen
können Herr Merz wäre ich sehr dankbar
und glücklich das wollte ich gesagt
haben zu diesem guten Vorschlag
und es ist aber richtig dass wir
gleichwohl auf europäischer Ebene
gemeinsame und konkrete Schritte gehen
beispielsweise der Vorschlag Verein
gemeinsam Gaseinkauf insbesondere für
die Füllung der gaspeicher was ja wieder
notwendig sein wird im kommenden Winter
für die Jahre 2023 und 24 ist es ein
richtiger Gedanke hier ein Mechanismus
zu finden die preisdynamiken im
europäischen Markt Gasmarkt zu
verringern denn insbesondere mit Blick
auf LNG ist die Dämpfung der Preise im
Großhandel durch neuer Referenzpunkte
extrem wichtig solche technischen Dinge
müssen auch europäischer Ebene geklärt
und gemacht werden daher ist es richtig
dass wir sowohl auf europäischer als
auch hier in Deutschland auf nationaler
Ebene jetzt Schritte einleiten auch zur
Ausweitung des Angebots und deswegen
habe ich es für richtig gehalten dass
der Bundeskanzler erklärt hat dass das
Bundeskabinett dass die Bundesregierung
den Deutschen Bundestag eine
Laufzeitverlängerung der Kernkraftwerke
über diesen Winter hinaus vorschlagen
wird allein das Kernkraftwerk im
niedersächsischen Emsland wird in dieser
Zeit 6,8 Millionen Menschen mit Strom
versorgen gleichzeitig müssen wir aber
auch daran
die diese Strom- und Gaspreise kann sich
kein privater Haushalt kann sich kein
mittelständisches Unternehmen leisten
und deswegen werden wir im Rahmen des
abwehrschirms eine gaspreisbremse und
eine strompreisbremse für Deutschland
installieren meine Damen und Herren die
200 Milliarden Euro die dort an
kreditermächtigung bereit werden
bereitgestellt werden sollen ist ja
nicht das Ziel einfach nur Geld
auszugeben meine Damen und Herren
sondern die klare Aussage zu tätigen mit
diesen hohen Preisen wird niemand allein
gelassen in Deutschland als
Solidargemeinschaft werden wir das
gemeinsam stemmen sein ganz ganz
wichtiges Signal dieser Tage lieber
Kollegen Kollegen und wir haben weiteres
getan die entlastungspakete sind von
meiner Kollegin Hasselmann vorhin schon
angesprochen worden auch die Volumen der
entlastungspakete suchen ihresgleichen
wir werden beispielsweise im Rahmen des
inflationsausgleichs bereits für das
kommende Jahr auch steuerlich die
Menschen unter die Arme greifen denn die
hart arbeitende Mitte in Deutschland die
diesen Steuerstaat trägt die hat genau
verdient liebe Kollegen Kollegen und wir
werden mit der gaspreisbremse über
Einmalzahlung im Dezember und dann
zu ellerung beim Gaspreis im kommenden
Jahr für die Unternehmen aber auch für
die industriellen Verbraucher und
insbesondere für die privaten Haushalte
die richtigen Schritte machen aber ich
will zum Schluss frau Präsidentin sagen
ich habe das vorne in Bezug auf die
Ukraine bezogen aber das gilt auch für
Deutschland und Europa wir sollten mehr
als nur raus aus der Krise wir wollen
eben auch an morgen denken meine Damen
und Herren und ich will an der Stelle
sagen dass deutsche
energiegeschäftsmodell die niedrigen
Gaspreise und gleichzeitig hohe
Unternehmenssteuern das ist dieser Tag
in Gefahr weil eine Säule weggebrochen
ist und deswegen müssen wir uns auch
energiepolitisch international
diversifizieren beispielsweise immer
energiepartnerschaften mit Afrika auf
der europäischen Ebene wird gerade das
Thema synthetische Kraftstoffe
verhandelt wie wäre es denn wenn wir
gemeinsam mit Afrika es hinbekommen dass
wir Energie von dort bekommen in Zukunft
aber gleichzeitig dadurch eben auch
zusätzliche Entwicklungsarbeit dort
betreiben können liebe Kollegen Kollegen
und ein ganz wichtiger Punkt heute
bereits an morgen zu denken ist dass wir
die nächste Krise die unseren Wohlstand
in Deutschland bedroht bereits in den
Blick nehmen und das ist der heftige
Arbeitskräftemangel bereits der kostet
uns bereits Wohlstand und
Wirtschaftswachstum deswegen wird diese
Koalition eine fachkräfteeinwanderung
bereits in dieser Woche mit einem ersten
Schritt und kommende Schritte werden in
diesen Monaten folgen auf den Weg
bringen meine Damen und Herren gerade
die Einwanderung in den deutschen
Arbeitsmarkt den Fehler der alten
unionsgeführten Bundesregierung endlich
zur korrigieren das wird Wohlstand in
Deutschland in Zukunft sichern meine
Damen und Herren und macht unser Land
aus krisenfester auch das will ich
unterstrichen haben
und
deswegen sage ich zum Schluss ich bin
für alle Vorschläge die dieser Tage
gemacht werden weil es gibt nicht den
einen perfekten Vorschlag sehr sehr
dankbar und Herr Merz sie haben mir in
ihrer Rede gerade immer wieder angemahnt
dass man mehr machen müsste aber das
Geheimnis was sie stattdessen
vorschlagen würden sind sie aus meiner
Sicht schuldig geblieben und das ist
nicht leicht keine Frage aber ich will
einen Vorschlag von ihnen aufgreifen der
vergleichsweise der vergleichsweise
konkret war sie haben gesagt anstatt 300
Euro für jeden sie haben ja gerade im
Finanzausschuss des Deutschen
Bundestages die 300 Euro für die
Rentnerinnen und rentnerbewusst
abgelehnt ich halte das für ein Fehler
aber das muss noch mal gesagt werden
aber ich will ihn ich will ihnen eins
sagen der Vorschlag zu sagen stattdessen
1000 Euro für das untere Drittel klingt
zunächst gut aber was heißt das denn
konkret was heißt das für den
Arbeitnehmer und die Arbeitnehmerin die
genau einen Euro mehr verdient als das
untere Drittel die gingen komplett leer
aus und da bin ich beim Bundes Kanzler
wir lassen in Deutschland niemanden
alleine ich bin dankbar für Vorschläge
der
Opposition das ist auch ihre Aufgabe
aber Sie müssen so konkret sein dass man
sie auch in deutsche Politik umsetzen
kann herzlichen Dank
das war Christian Dörr von der FDP er
entgegnete der AFD dass Deutschland sich
nicht aus dem besten verabschieden werde
genau das wolle Putin doch die Spaltung
des Westens nächste Rednerin ist nun
Amira Mohammed Ali Fraktionschefin der
Linken
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
Bundeskanzler sie und ihre
Regierungsmitglieder nennen sich ja
selbst gern die
fortschrittskoalition leider ist das
einzige was in unserem Land ernsthaft
voranschreitet die Spaltung der
Gesellschaft Millionen Menschen wissen
nicht mehr wie sie ihr ganz normales
Leben bezahlen wollen unsere Wirtschaft
droht eine schwere Rezession in ihrer
Regierung aber herrscht das Chaos und
wenn es darum geht die Bevölkerung
wirksam zu entlasten dann wird endlos
gezögert und gezaudert und was dann
rauskommt ist meistens morgens Chaos und
Murks bei den spärlichen
entlastungspäckchen Chaos am Umgang mit
Christian Lindners heiliger Kuh der
Schuldenbremse und auch die
atomkraftdebatte hat wieder gezeigt dass
es ihnen vor allem darum geht den
jeweiligen Befindlichkeiten ihrer
Minister gerecht zu werden und eben
nicht um die Belange der Bevölkerung
aber das geht so nicht
man stelle sich einmal vor Sie hätten
all die Stunden die sich sinnlos
gestritten haben dafür genutzt die
Menschen vor der Preisexplosion wirksam
zu schützen indem sie zum Beispiel den
versprochenen strompreisdeckel
eingeführt hätten oder einen
vernünftigen gaspreisdeckel und zwar
jetzt und ich am Ende der Heizperiode im
März was ist das denn
und auch heute haben sie sich wieder
gelobt für ihre lächerlichen
entlastungspäckchen und ich möchte dazu
eines sagen ich meine sie als
Norddeutscher sollten doch wissen es
reicht nicht den Deich auf zwei Meter
aufzuschütten bei 10 Meter Hochwasser da
braucht es mehr und die Katastrophe zu
verhindern das ist die Wahrheit wir
brauchen sofort ein energiepreisdeckel
Verbrauch ohne Verbraucher genauso wie
die kleinen und mittelständischen
Unternehmen und zwar auch bezahlbaren
Niveau außerdem müssen alle Haushalte
mit kleinen und mittleren Einkommen
wirksam entlastet werden wir wollen 1500
Euro wintergeld pro Haushalt plus 600
Euro für jedes weitere Haushaltsmitglied
das würde wirklich etwas bringen und
wenn sie sagen dass dafür kein Geld da
sein dann ist das einfach Quatsch
besteuern sie endlich die perversen
übergewinne der Energiekonzerne die
liegen jetzt schon bei über 100
Milliarden Euro außerdem führen sie
endlich eine gerechte Vermögensteuer ein
ich meine wenn Sie trotz dieser
existenziellen Krise immer noch nicht
bereit sind die Superreichen gerecht zu
besteuern dann regieren sie einfach an
den Belangen der Mehrheit vorbei so ist
das leider und außerdem muss
selbstverständlich die Schuldenbremse
auch im nächsten Jahr ausgesetzt werden
alles andere ist unverantwortlich
Vernunft vor Ideologie das muss auch in
der Finanzpolitik endlich gelten
der Präsident
der Chemieindustrie der warnt davor
Deutschland könne vom Industrieland zum
Industriemuseum werden in der
Stahlbranche droht aktuell tausenden
Arbeiterinnen und Arbeitern der
Arbeitsplatzverlust denn wenn sich die
Lage nicht bald deutlich verbessert dann
wird die Produktion nach und nach in
Länder mit geringeren Energiekosten
verlagert werden das darf nicht
passieren Kolleginnen und Kollegen
auch ihre außenpolitische Bilanz die ist
leider ernüchternd ja seit fast acht
Monaten tobt bereits Putins
schrecklicher Krieg in der Ukraine und
es muss doch eigentlich endlich auch bei
Ihnen die Erkenntnis gereift sein dass
dieser Krieg nicht weiter eskalieren
darf nein er muss möglichst schnell
beendet werden und das geht nur über
Verhandlungen ja es braucht jetzt
Diplomatie statt Waffenlieferungen und
es geht eben nicht das möchte ich mal in
aller Deutlichkeit sagen dass denjenigen
die das aussprechen was vernünftig ist
das Dehnen unterstellt wird dass sie
Verständnis hätten für Putin das ist
einfach Blödsinn und es macht das
Geschäft genau von denen die diese argum
hier instrumentalisierend für ihre Hetze
das ist die Wahrheit das ist
instrumentell sie sind doch sonst immer
für Aufrüstung nein unsere Haltung ist
der konsequent nur differativ und
Vernunft sind der richtige Weg und das
gleiche das gleiche gilt übrigens auch
für berechtigte Kritik an den
allgemeinen Wirtschaftssanktionen fakt
ist diese Sanktionen die Schaden
Deutschland der EU und den Ländern des
globalen Südens enorm Russlands
Kriegsmaschinerie rollt aber
unbeeindruckt weiter die russische
Wirtschaft ist weiterhin stabil herr
Scholz sie haben selbst versprochen es
würde keine Sanktionen geben die uns
mehr Schaden als Russland handeln sie
endlich danach
und bevor sie uns jetzt weiter oder
wiederkommen mit ihrer angeblichen
wertebasierten Außenpolitik sie
unterhalten beste Beziehung zu
Diktaturen wie zum Beispiel nach Saudi
Arabien dahin liefern sie jetzt sogar
Kampfjets Kampfjets mit denen die sauge
Luftmasse Waffe systematisch Zivilisten
im Jemen bombardiert in diesem
schrecklichen Krieg sind bereits 400.000
Zivilisten ermordet worden und das
Sterben geht weiter und ihre
Außenministerin an einer der wehrbock
die sagt dazu allen Ernstes man müsste
ja nun mal die Bündnisverpflichtung
erfüllen und ohne diese Lieferung der
Kampfjet und Saudi-Arabien kümmerte
Deutschland in sozialen Bereich ja noch
mehr sparen Kampfjets für die
Kindergrundsicherung so stand es
treffend im Spiegel ich meine wie
zynisch ist das denn und wie zynisch ist
das eigentlich den Kindern im Jemen
gegenüber nein Menschenrechte die müssen
immer und überall gelten und eben nicht
nur da und dann wenn es in
geopolitischen in den Kram passt danke
so wir blenden uns hier aus der Debatte
über die Regierungserklärung des
Kanzlers aus meine Kollegin Ines Trams
hat ja vor Ort die Debatte beobachtet
Ines wie hast du das denn heute
empfunden also es gab ja von Seiten der
Opposition viele Vorwürfe in Richtung
des Kanzlers es gäbe zu wenig Konkretes
man müsste noch nicht genau wie die
Bürger entlastet werden wie war das wie
hast du das empfunden heute
ich denke europäische Solidarität war
die Hauptaussage von Kanzler Scholz in
seiner heutigen Regierungserklärung
Europa der Westen stehe zusammen betonte
er immer wieder und an Putin gerichtet
meinte er du hast dich verrechnet wir
der Westen lässt sich weder
einschüchtern noch Spalten mit Blick auf
das Thema Energiesicherheit sieht Scholz
Deutschland gut aufgestellt er sagt aber
auch die Preise für Gas und Strom die
müssten runter und den Anlehnung an sein
durchgängiges Motto Motto you never walk
alone sagte er keiner solle sich in
diesem Winter kein Rentner kein Student
sorgen solle Angst haben vor den
explodierenden Energiepreisen konkret
wurde er allerdings erneut nicht mit
Blick auf das 200 Milliarden Euro
Entlastungspaket und genau das machte
Oppositionsführer
unionsfraktionschef Merz ihm zum Vorwurf
wie soll denn dieser 200 Milliarden Euro
doppelwumms tatsächlich aussehen wie und
wann sollen die Entlastungen bei
Haushalten bei den Bürgern und bei den
Unternehmen ankommen es war ja nun das
erste öffentliche Aufeinandertreffen
aller Koalitionspartnern nach dem
Machtwort des Kanzlers zum Atomstreit
wie ist denn dein Eindruck wie war denn
das Verhältnis innerhalb der Regierung
innerhalb der Ampel
also mein Eindruck war dass heute hier
im Plenum ja wo man sich dann auch das
erste mal wieder als Ampelkoalition der
Öffentlichkeit präsentiert hat dass man
da tatsächlich zusammengestanden hat das
also grüne gerade auch die grüne Frau
Hasselmann aus der Fraktion sich gewandt
hat gegen märz gegen die Opposition ihm
vorgeworfen hat dass er selber dass er
als Opposition ja auch keine konkreten
Lösungsvorschläge für die anstehende
Energiekrise machen würde also da war
mein Eindruck steht man zusammen Scholz
verwies darauf was man alles getan hätte
um sich vorzubereiten und erschloss
natürlich auch darin ein seine
Entscheidung die drei noch verbleibenden
Atommeiler weiter in diesem Winter am
Netz zu lassen
ja für heute herzlichen Dank an Ines
Trams hier geht es jetzt weiter im
Programm mit der Sendung Notruf
Hafenkante ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen
schönen Tag bedanke mich für Interesse
und sage Tschüss bis zum nächsten Mal
[Musik]